Let's look at the solution to
our flat page table size quiz.
We are asked what the total size of
the page tables in the system is.
There are two processes in the system,
so there will be two page tables.
We need to add up their sizes.
The page size is 4 kilobytes.
The applications have a 32-bit
virtual address space.
So we have 2 processes times 2
to the 32nd bytes of address
space divided by 2 to
the 12 bytes in a page.
This is how many pages we have times
the size of an entry is 8 bytes,
which gives us two times
eight is 16 x 2 to the 20th.
2 to the 20th bytes is a megabyte,
So we have 16 megabytes.
Note that it didn't matter how much
memory the processes are actually using.
The flat page table needs to have
an entry for every possible page
in the virtual address space, not only
for the pages we are actually using.
Also, it doesn't matter how much
physical memory we actually have.
What matters is what
the size of the entry is.
So for example, this entry was
designed to accommodate up to a 64-bit
physical address, even though the system
actually has much less memory.
Why would you do this?
Well, because you want to build
the system such that it can expand its
memory if necessary, for example,
by adding more memory modules.